alright so here i am in Jerusalem they
say the holiest place on earth this is
the cradle of civilization right so
right there is the western wall that is
just that wall where this greenery
growing out of it that is the holiest
site in Judaism it's the last remaining
wall of the old temple on top of it
that's the Dome of the rock right there
and this is a laksa mosque that
everybody's talking about now all right
there you can see it's actually pretty
quiet here I've seen people from every
ethnicity and religion and Muslims and
Jews and Christians and black people and
white people and Asian people everybody
all getting along walking next to each
other eating at the same restaurant I
know nobody in the news ever wants you
to see any of that but that's a truth
unfortunately we can't go to a laksa
mosque right now they actually what they
don't let you spray up there not that I
was going to go up there pray but it's I
guess it's closed for tourists in
general right now
but I thought this would be an
interesting place to do a video because
it's a good angle of how these things
are literally on top of each other these
holy things for people are literally on
top of each other but there's a lot of
coexistence here so
you know people want everyone to think
everybody's fighting all the time yeah
this is some prime real estate but
there's also some goodness or anything
there's some there's call to prayer I
think that's a Muslim call to prayer all
right more to come